hey everybody and welcome to an
exhilarating wild ride with stevo this
one is just plain fun we've got the
wildly successful entrepreneur and
youtuber codyco and he isn't just wildly
successful he is hilarious
and handsome so
just strap on your seatbelts and get
ready to get into it
are we recording on all cameras we sure
are we are all right are we uh recording
everywhere
at this point i'd be dripping sweat like
uh the wires are [ __ ] being crossed
i'm leaving this in
i was uh traveling i went home to the
midwest oh nice yeah how was that it was
nice very nice all right and he got
engaged no way we got engaged
congratulations
thank you who takes two [ __ ] weeks to
ask one question
man
you're just sweating for two weeks i was
dude
when do i do it
all right ladies and gentlemen cody co
yeah dude
so bad thank you so much for having me
sorry to interrupt i'm not good i'm just
i was so stoked
when they reached out and they said
steva wants you to be on i was like yes
can i say yes
three times yeah and then thank god
because i dare say we are in a little
bit of a slump
i shouldn't say that but
we don't want to say that but but dude
i'm an open book man and from what i
understand on the audio side we're very
consistent but it's on the youtube side
that people are so finicky
that like some podcasts are wildly
popular and our last
sure four five six i know there's
something against the guests they are
great shows they just didn't get the
numbers i'm not saying that we've done
we haven't made a bet and i would rather
have a great episode that's got low
viewership than a shitty episode that's
got a lot yeah i hear that so in that
respect we are on fire
we enjoy doing it that's what that's all
that matters yeah this one's going to be
a shitty episode that doesn't get a lot
of views
it's going to be the worst of both
worlds that's what i've learned about
you is that uh you're quick to be
self-deprecating
it's endearing i think that's one thing
that uh made jackass a cultural
phenomenon that uh
we did we took it a step further we were
comfortable looking super uncool yeah
yeah but you guys were legends though
yeah you were pretty cool at the same
time yeah you kind of walked that line
right so so yeah i'd say thank you for
doing it you know i i think that this
episode's going to be a performer and i
think it's going to be a great episode
uh and before we started recording
pressure's on you said that uh
that you said that you had sent me a dm
did i respond to it no you didn't even
read it i never never even said well i
mean i wasn't really expecting you to
and then i saw that you followed me so i
was like oh my god
and i was like stoked about that like in
the first place and then i because i've
been obsessed with like watching van
life videos and stuff like that and
like i'm a big surfer too and so it's
like kind of my dream to buy one of
these things and just go down to like
huntington and surf for the whole day
like just do a morning session post up
in here drink a beer whatever and then
go out in the evening i mean dude that's
easy that's easy but why's why it
stopped there i mean [ __ ] you could go
up to
or
go
oh yeah i've heard that
i mean i've been there but not like in a
van like this i've heard that's like
ideal yeah i kind of want to [ __ ] go
serve tofino british columbia it's like
i'm from calgary canada
yeah have you served never but i've i've
always wanted to i've been there a
couple times have you yeah and is it
good is it fun i had fun you've been a
couple times i have i went uh
in january of 2013. rough
so you were like full hood booties
gloves yeah was it similar to alaska
alaska was
um
more intense
cold wise i'm already getting in trouble
with people for talking too much about
me dude i got a [ __ ] i got i got a
cody code right here
when did you start surfing
uh like
seven years ago now probably so i was
like 23.
and so you moved from canada and you
went to college here i went to college
in north carolina yeah duke duke uh
diver yeah yeah platform diver
springboard diver springboard diver i
yeah it's brutal what do you mean it
hurts why because you're so high up in
the squat perfect every time yeah when
you come from 33.33
feet you ever dove off the 10 meter and
like did like twists and turns yeah i've
done a front one and a half so like a
front flip to a dive off ten meter that
was like the most complicated it got for
me up there and then i was like it sucks
i'm not doing this yeah it's just rough
like even even when you enter the water
perfectly it's so much stress on the
shoulders and i don't know how people do
that for years and years and years how
do you sorry how do divers have such
good bodies if all they do is dive all
day i mean they're jacked and they're
ripped are they working out yeah you do
like an hour of like dry land beforehand
which is like abs
like a lot of them have like diving
boards that go into maths and it's like
you know diving itself is like a huge
like cardio muscle combination
i would think it's a lot of core too
just like getting your body yeah
especially the platform divers with the
arm stands like uh all these arm stand
dives are pretty heavy plus just getting
out of the pool that many times dude
that's a lot of wraps that's true i mean
that's a that's like a
serious push-up dude that's true yeah
um
are you familiar with the name brian
galuli no okay because he was the 1994
senior diving champion after winning a
record 10 consecutive junior national
titles and he taught me how to do
standing back flips which i quickly uh
turned into simultaneous fire breathing
standing back flips which then turned
into tucking your dick between your legs
that's what we did for diving workouts
too yeah yeah yeah everyone right tuck
the dicks
uh so you're an ncaa springboard diving
table one meter three meter yeah yeah
and uh like
what uh
what was your most technical dive on the
three meter
uh front two and a half double twist
that was my hardest dive and also
probably my best because it's like the
highest degree of difficulty so you get
the most points have you posted on your
ig what we call a ripper
like a no splash where you ripped it and
then it's so crazy like the rip
it's called like it's called ripping it
where not only is there no splash but
like you create this vacuum as you go in
and so it like sucks in like
and then just bubbles up like whoa yeah
you that's why they call it a rip
because it's like the sound sounds like
you're ripping it's like a very
particular sound
yeah uh yeah that's how often does that
happen in the diving world dude this
last olympics it happened like every
[ __ ] time for this chinese girl like
the 13 year old or 14 year old one on
the 10 meter i couldn't believe that she
got trends on like everything you never
see that straight
across the board on everybody she's also
like 40 pounds
wow i mean dude that will never be
beaten i don't i don't know how you
could ever beat that like that was the
most dominant olympic performance
ever it really was incredible jesus yeah
the movie conehead she dove pretty good
so you have uh you've got footage of
good rippers like mine yeah i got a
couple good rippers
i got some footage but like
i'm so bad at like like backing up hard
drives and making sure when i get a new
computer i like you know take care of
the old footage so it's all sitting
somewhere on an old computer in like my
closet and i have no idea where it is i
have trouble believing that i have
trouble believing that you're an
unorganized person oh i absolutely am oh
yeah i'm a scatter brain
all right i try to be organized but it's
just i don't know i want to do like a
million things
how long ago i'm constantly thinking
about how long ago was that epic
beef with jake paul
oh we're gonna get all up into cody and
jake's beef but first let me tell you
about mine with plastic it is destroying
the environment and you want to know
who's doing something about it the good
people at liquid death
yeah it's water and a big beautiful tall
boy that looks just like a beer can and
you know what's special about these cans
they're infinitely recyclable so that's
the whole deal death to plastic and
murder your thirst with this delicious
sparkling water and they've also got
that gorgeous pure mountain spring water
from like
austria dude come on this company's
great i love them and you see how much
better i look lately it's because i'm
drinking more water turns out it's
really good for you
and you can feel super good about saving
the world when you're drinking liquid
death and they got a great new deal and
i'm excited to tell you about it if you
go to liquiddeth.como
you've got free shipping on every order
of water and merch and let me tell you
their merch is hilarious
so for free shipping on all your orders
of water in merch go to liquiddeath.com
stevo and once again look better because
you're drinking more water feel better
because you're shaping the world and be
better because you're a wild dried
listener
now let's talk about that beef
that was like
almost two years ago now i think yeah
maybe longer maybe three years yeah
maybe three years
that was uh
that was something else huh it was
pretty wild
and
so just and now he could beat the [ __ ]
out of me i mean he broke it back then
too right like uh i mean it wasn't
anything terribly aggressive that you
had done right like you just sort of
made a reaction video to his rapping and
called it cringy and like
like it and so then
he shows up just bum rushes you on like
some set that you were working on and
like really aggro and like ah come on
come on
yeah it was supposed to be like a joke
like the guy that
right
yeah he was like thought that he'd be
kind of like in on the joke right and
then he came in he like used it as an
opportunity like film it himself
right and uh yeah the whole thing felt
just really weird i was like really
uncomfortable like afterwards i was like
man i feel like i don't know what the
[ __ ] just happened right
it was really bizarre i think i read
that i think it read that way that like
when you saw him you were like oh hey
man i'm [ __ ] cool dude like like you
know you could tell that there was
nothing
like there's no real like malice or
animosity on your part right yeah and he
came with this crazy energy
um and what what was most odd i think to
me was that it was jake himself who put
out the video
that just felt like awkward and weird
yeah and kind of like you you looked
like
uh
he kind of felt like he put out a video
that made you look good
and he didn't look bad i don't know the
whole situation was so so bizarre plus i
had a fresh cut
i just got a fresh haircut i looked
incredible
he accused you of being a bully
yeah cyberbullying yeah
yeah did that change your uh your
approach to
internet bullying
yeah i started bullying in a different
way
i think you know i think like you know
sometimes i go back and i watch those
old videos
like that's cringes and stuff like that
that we used to do
the ones that he was pissed about i mean
i don't even know if he was pissed at
the one that we did about him he
probably was but i go back and watch
those and sometimes i'm like man we did
go really [ __ ] hard but it's like
it's a young dude thing you know you
mid 20s you think you're the [ __ ] man
you can't do any wrong and then you get
to 30 and you're like i just like you
know i just want everybody to like me
yeah and it's just like i just
i'm getting older now and it's like you
know as cliche as it sounds it's like
negativity doesn't really breed
anything like the ceiling is pretty low
wow so like now it's like we we do
you know we still are trying to remain
edgy and like we're comedians so we you
know like to make fun of [ __ ] but um
in a little bit of a lighter-hearted way
i guess i don't know now when you say we
like uh you have a distinct crew
i mean i do my podcasts i do with noel
like my comedy partner and then i do
videos of my girlfriend kelsey we make
content together no well
wait were you guys
in
vancouver and we met and yes yes at the
just for laughs thing yeah
dude
you hung out watch my show noel did i
didn't we went and watched it she was
like [ __ ] that no i wouldn't i would
totally would have been there kelsey
wanted to see uh one of her favorite
comedians and so it was just on the
street and so he walked down right right
but i heard that your show is phenomenal
and also like insanely gross and like
disturbing
i think your tour manager was like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i think we
talked to you at the bar then afterwards
you said that like every show multiple
people have to leave for because
completely unconscious sometimes they
hit their heads and it's it's a because
they're from one of the bits in the show
which is the vasectomy olympics right
right yeah yeah there's a lot of fun man
it's a lot of pressure this is great
dude
we spoke we did it was yeah we did yeah
i remember that yep yeah we had the same
uh contact person at full screen yeah
you used to work at full screen i did
yeah i read that yep i was repped by
them and i worked for them as a software
engineer
doesn't even exist anymore yeah they
just like they just like dissolved
pretty much oh yeah and it seems that uh
i mean it's always like a an evolving
moving world of you know digital content
creation and now i think we're in a
climate that really doesn't favor being
with uh a network like full screen yeah
there's just no reason to be anymore
yeah i don't think
you know unless you need like help with
production but like no but they don't
even really offer that i don't think oh
yeah
okay
it was mostly just like an mcn
type thing which 10 years ago used to be
huge because they would help you like
collab with other youtubers and stuff
that stuff like doesn't really mean as
much anymore well collabing with
youtubers certainly means it means
everything that always but you can just
reach out to a youtuber and do it
yourself yeah and it's a different type
of thing like the relationship used to
be like
like we'll do an eight-minute video on
your channel and then we'll do them on
my channel where we don't think about
the concepts at all it's just the fact
that we're on each other's channels will
drive our audience it doesn't really
work like that anymore it's like you
actually have to think about the way
you're collaborating with people like
doing this stuff and yeah
um yeah i'm pretty protective in general
like my my feeling is that if if it's
about showing up on someone else's
channel
then like i'm a [ __ ] you know yeah i'm
there dude the ones you did with steve
will do it were amazing like that's
that's a great collab what thanks man i
watched every angle of that [ __ ] on his
channel on your channel i was like i
couldn't get enough dad how's your ear
i will gladly tell you all about my ear
just as soon as i get done telling you
about my dick because in about a half an
hour from now it is gonna be properly
hard as a rock why because i am treating
myself to a blue chew tablet get out of
here you little
now what is a blue chew tablet well it's
a delicious chewable tablet with the
same active ingredients as both viagra
and cialis
and
that makes you hard as a rock i've tried
it many many times and i absolutely love
it you know who else loves it
when i take one lux because
when i show her my blue tongue
she's jumping for joy because she knows
she's gonna get drilled in a serious way
so let me tell you about this because
not only is a lot of fun but when you
get your bluetooth tablets it's really
easy doesn't require you to go to any
awkward
in-person doctor visit
now at bluechew.com you consult with one
of their medical providers right on the
website super quick super easy and then
boom you're good to go and if at
bluetooth.com you use the promo code
stevo you get an entire month's supply
of bluetooth tablets absolutely for free
all you gotta pay is five bucks for
shipping so
come on i mean if it ever occurred to
you that it might be a lot of fun to try
a bluetooth tablet now is the time to
pull the trigger because you know why
it's fall man falls here and everybody
could use a good stiff breeze
so head on over to bluechew.com
use the promo code stevo and get
yourself an entire month's supply of
bluetooth tablets absolutely for free
and pay nothing but five dollars for
shipping yeah
and
then get ready to have a good time
now let's get back to it man
dated my ear [ __ ] healed up on its
own did it really back to normal dude
out of the woods i'm wolverine that's
wild i couldn't believe when you were
like doing this and it was whistling
yeah i don't even know it worked like
that i know dude i sent a video of me
with my whistling trick to dr drew oh
he's my guy
he said dr drew is my guy was he like
that's not supposed to do that he said
he said you definitely have a ruptured
tympanic membrane which is just him
showing off having a fancy word for your
turn right we get it dude you're the
doctor we get it bro
yeah that's cool yeah and then we saw
steve will do it this last weekend over
in uh yeah
that was funny how was that it was cool
he came to my show i went back up with
the bucket list tour he came oh nice he
came to the show and there's a portion
of it where he you know he walked up and
he's like he's like i want to buy some
merch he said i was like all right dude
and then he's like i want to buy
everything by a million dollars worth of
emergency
and then when he was paying he was like
is there like a tip button here and i'm
like there's not dude and i'm like god
damn it why isn't there a tip but
he would have just took me like 87
i'll take you know i take chains or
watches whatever you want to give me he
was just like are you sure there's no
tip button here and he's like waiting
for me i'm like yeah it's not dude
there's no tip button but there is a
lamborghini dealership just
i know and i'm not i'm not like quick
enough to be like you know some sort of
jive to like oh no we can just do this
but custom work i was just like [ __ ]
dude yeah
i mean i watched your podcast with him
because i was i was also curious about
the rate at which he spends money
because it's really
unbelievable like it is and i mean it's
it's working like it's people love
watching his videos because they're like
what's he gonna buy this week yeah and
so it like kind of fuels the whole
ecosystem but it's unbelievable i mean
it's like
it's like irresponsible but it's it's
fun to watch i cannot fly that you're
like
yeah it's such a [ __ ] fascinating
thing and you look at david dobrik
giving away like cars every video like
david dobrik's print but david dobrik is
so evidently
calculated and strategic and whenever
he's giving something away it's
something that like
came from the sponsor anyway you know
like and it's super tied in like very
strategically to the sponsorship you
know so you know david dobrik is really
uh
you know kind of pro about it whereas
what makes steve will do it so
compelling is that he's just [ __ ] out
of his mind that like it's so clearly
not strategic and he's just it's
compulsive it's like how much is that
sure let's do it right [ __ ] it you want
one too great we'll get you too your dog
wants one we'll get one for her too i
think i think compulsive is a good word
for it and and what i wanted to urge
steve will do it to do
is watch this documentary called broke
okay it's a documentary it's [ __ ]
fascinating about like
how like such the overwhelming majority
of professional athletes
who earn
tens of or hundreds of millions of
dollars in their career like are
completely broke within five years of
their professional career ending you
know and like
so
when i saw it i was like oh my god i'm
never gonna delete this off my ipad like
i wanted a constant reminder of like
don't think that money coming in is how
it's always gonna be yeah and and then
like
but the thing is
with steve will do it i wonder if that's
even applicable because he's making so
much [ __ ] money i know yeah but it's
kind of like what shaq said it's like
okay cool we made 20 million but you
didn't make 20 million you made 10
million right like i wonder tax time
happens is he's just like [ __ ] but is
that a write-off for steve like i gave
away like three million likes
that's gotta go yeah
the one thing that i wonder about
i don't know like i don't know who is
doing his taxes but that person must be
stressed
it's like mike mike tyson's tax guy in
the 80s
exactly
you bought a tiger can we write that
um off mike tyson had a mansion for his
tigers next door
9 000 square foot mansion for them as
their cat house jesus christ i mean
that's just that's just smart money
though that's a smart purchase
what i wonder is that like my friend and
fellow youtuber danny did a video about
duncan danny gonzalez okay he did a
video about like the logistics of giving
someone a car because it's right it's
not just here's a ferrari it's like
here's a ferrari in a [ __ ] ton of taxes
that you have to pay on this car and so
a lot of people like like all kinds of
people who won game shows got in serious
trouble with the irs because yeah
because a lot of the times it says like
on you know like giveaway rules and
stuff like that if you read the terms
it's like you can't sell it within the
first month
so people go broke because they were
given this crazy gift and they can't
afford it yeah so i'm wondering like
steve giving these people ferraris and
stuff it's like the most expensive car
you can have
what's the aftermath of that is like
like is it under their name
is under steve's name and they can just
drive it forever
yeah i know what george clooney uh
i remember there's an article on george
clooney he made like 10 of his friends
millionaires but he gave him a million
and then he gave him 300 000 on top of
it to pay the taxes on the million yeah
i thought that was pretty yeah that is
cool i i've heard that story
um
he like apparently took his
buddies out for dinner
at this place in in mexico and
it was like 10 of his best friends from
college or whatever this is right after
he sold casamigos
and he was like all right everyone i
want everyone to reach under the table
and there was an envelope with a million
bucks in there that's great yeah
man
that's uh it's like i would never
[ __ ] do that
i'm kidding well it's an awkward thing
you know like like money is is like an
awkward thing and it's
like well it's not i mean i can't
picture george clooney being awkward in
any situation
but like
here's a crazy thing that happened i
went out to dinner
with steve wozniak one of the
co-founders of apples right and
of course the guy's [ __ ] rich because
he's a co-founder of apple
and uh
like when it came time for the check to
come
it's like
he just steve wozniak just pipes up he
says
since i picked the restaurant i'm paying
the tab you know i'm covering the check
and and i just felt there was so much to
that because it's like
i felt what he was really saying was i'm
not
paying for dinner because i'm [ __ ]
rich
i'm paying because i picked the
restaurant and he it was important to
him it felt to me to make that
distinction
because it's his way of having
boundaries you know like and you didn't
want to like disrespect anyone who might
be like i could pay for my own meal i
was i was super impressed by it like it
was just it felt like healthy boundaries
and like and he said it joyfully you
know like i picked the restaurant i love
this place and that's why i'm paying
yeah
yeah i think for
uh george clooney was like listen i just
made 500 million like i'm
i don't care how much you guys make i
just want to give some he's like you
know that steve will do it you know
that's that kind of stuff
yeah how do you know about that because
like because that's the other thing that
makes it weird is when you draw
attention to it which that the george
learning thing how do i know that story
like yeah well i've heard the story too
but yeah did he tell people or did his
friends tell people right it's
yeah by the way i just gave my buddies
like 10 million bucks so
i hate those youtube videos where people
are like all right we're gonna go pay
people's rent and then they go
door-to-door and film how good of a deed
they're doing yeah
do that without the camera right yeah
like it's just kind of cringy i agree i
completely agree i it always rubs me the
wrong way like the artificial positivity
the the good samaritan [ __ ] for views
but then again at the same time
it makes people happy that's why that
content's popular yeah so like i'm a
little torn about it sure just look at
it and watch it and know that that guy
is just doing it for selfish reasons
because he gets a lot of views probably
but even if it's self-serving he also
just paid those people's rent like
they're not complaining they're like
yeah i mean you did that for yourself
but also my rent is now paid for the
year so yeah it's helping people but it
is very self-serving so i i agree it's
such a paradox
right or not maybe they should donate
the money that they make from that video
to break even maybe something or they
should
like take the money back
yeah
just so like you know there's not a
double intention there it's like no this
is just for youtube
there's no confusion it's completely
self-serving you didn't actually think
we were going to do that did you oh my
god but but only after the cameras stop
rolling yes exactly yeah
i just want to throw it out there all
right i do all kinds of that stuff like
without ever even mentioning it just
want to put that
same sound
i mean you wouldn't believe this so i'm
not going to mention it though but it's
like it's crazy
so
i'm curious about the app that you made
how long did it take you to make the app
and then i know there's two different
thoughts because you
what are you laughing at over here
i've never mentioned it
[Laughter]
um okay i had a question so you made an
app and it was top of the apple store
for apps
okay
did it cost you a lot of money to make
the app because i've had the idea to
make some apps he's had a million ideas
he had like he's and so when you bring
him to these companies that make the
apps for you they're like okay it's
gonna be like a hundred grand and then
there's other people like no we can make
these apps for like you know five ten
grand my question is if you're gonna go
with the company that's gonna make an
app for you for like a thousand to five
thousand dollars
chances are it's probably not gonna get
on the apple store you're better off
paying the hundred thousand dollars for
like the software and you have better
chances at having a better
i you know what i'm trying to say like
it sounds like the people who only
charge five or 10 grand are gonna take a
revenue share right
no i mean i don't know it depends how
complex the app is
can you make can i make an app myself
without going to a firm and doing that
and then and then i get it on the apple
store and my chances are pretty good
yeah you could do that anyone's cody's
expression is like how do i be kind and
shut down
listen it's been a long time since i
programmed or wrote a line of code or
you know even opened up like xcode which
is a program that you use to make apps
so i don't even know what the current
landscape is like i really don't i just
i know that
you know people
the app
kind of golden era like the gold rush
age is kind of over in terms of apps
yeah you know now everyone's like crypto
that's what everyone's focused on
in the tech world
now both of these guys ears just perked
up they love crypto i like really yeah
yeah are you invested in the crypto yeah
yeah i think of course no i mean not of
course it only i actually bought bitcoin
in 2012
like when i read an article about it
like i like i said i used to work for a
startup i was a software engineer so
super
like you know involved in reading all
the tech news and and i read hacker news
all the time and did you see this
documentary called shiny flakes not
netflix it's about a [ __ ]
teenage
drug lord
who became like
[ __ ] like this
on the dark web or whatever out of his
childhood bedroom at his parents house
and and it's uh it all happened in
germany this [ __ ] kid had like a ton
of drugs in his bed like actually a ton
and and like all kinds and this
documentary on netflix is uh it wasn't
made in german but it's over dubbed and
it's completely watchable huh but my
girl and i looks we watched the whole
thing and we were just [ __ ]
and it was on the silk road he was
sending i don't know about it so i've
never heard of silk road was a dark web
or how you used to buy drugs i think
this kid had the [ __ ] website just on
the regular web
she bought a bitcoin
and that what was a bitcoin at that time
i think it was 200 bucks i think it was
and i bought it for around 150 to 200
bucks and i didn't have a ton of money
back then so i you know that even was
like a huge risk it was like this is a
decent amount of my rent this month but
like i this is a really cool idea and i
kind of believe in this i could see how
this would be gigantic in the future
and then last year was like the first
time that i actually put like real money
into
into bitcoin and ethereum and now i've
been like doing the nft thing over the
past couple weeks
so you're selling nft i sold one well
i'm trading them i'm doing the like day
trading nfts i guess flipping them yeah
i made nine grand yesterday just on that
getting art flipping it yeah i couldn't
[ __ ] believe it so the nft gold rush
is still ongoing yes it's it's in the
middle of it right now i think i don't
know i've only been doing it for a week
so
i on like last week i bought my first
one to try and flip it just to try and
learn and then every day i've been like
spending a couple hours learning about
it
and to me
to my knowledge right now i think it's
like you know the the peak of it so it's
like a good time to get in and try to
make some money what do you think
there's so many revenue streams that i'm
just sitting on my ass not getting
around to twitch
yeah
nfts only fans
drops drops
goddamn you mean like merch drops yeah
yeah yeah i mean there's there's time
though like people have been doing merch
drops forever but there's a lot of ways
for people to make money when they think
that you know there's only one way to
make money go to a nine-to-five job
collect a check but dude you can
reinvent yourself there's a ton of cash
to be made out there yeah i feel like a
lot of people don't realize that right
yeah especially like in the creator
economy right now jesus dude do you have
a patreon i don't so for our podcast we
do like one episode that we put out for
free every week and then in the same
filming session we'll film another hour
and we'll put that up for our patreon
subscribers
and that's worked really well for us we
have like 23
000 paying customers monthly paying
customers which is great because it's
like guaranteed income that we can just
put back into the company and buy more
stuff for the podcast and make the show
better dude that's kind of [ __ ] epic
do you decide after the fact which hour
will be free and which hour will be paid
does it sometimes flip-flop
it's always
we're always a little bit more like
loose and relaxed in the in the bonus
one because it's like it's behind the
paywall so it's like right not everyone
can see it so we're kind of like yeah we
talk a little more [ __ ] and stuff like
that i did steve will do it posted on
instagram like night before last that he
he says i'm streaming
on twitch
from north korea
i'm like come on get the [ __ ] and
then he says lincoln bio so i'm like
dude i gotta [ __ ] it
so i open up my twitch app which is like
got dust all over it and and and
he's doing his gambling thing like the
first thing i hear him say is like dude
we [ __ ] lost everything
we were up two hundred thousand dollars
now we have nothing
like that
he was in between two crazy statues
which really did seem to lend
credibility to north korea and uh so i'm
like i don't care i'm not i'm in the
twitch app and i'm like
like yo dawg are you seriously in north
korea i write this comment try to post
it it says you have to be a subscriber
to yeah
comments and i'm like [ __ ] so
you pulled out your credit card and the
comments are just from like every one of
these people just paying him yeah i
didn't pull out my credit card but i did
[ __ ] make a mental note to stop
[ __ ] blowing it i started thinking
that
what if we had a live twitch just a
[ __ ] cell phone sitting here so if
you're a twitch subscriber or maybe or
whatever you can
do be at the podcast while it's
happening
yeah yeah you could definitely do that
so that someone says the wrong thing
that we wanted to edit out but now it's
live and it's out there yeah yeah yeah
they're paying but but you know you know
what the other thing we
should shouldn't be sleeping on uh
release forms
we don't have to worry about that if
people [ __ ] sign a release form when
uh
yeah well i think the video like them
acknowledging at the end that like is
there anything that you're right but but
if it's gonna be on twitch we want them
to acknowledge in writing at the
beginning yeah that's true so then i'd
be [ __ ]
it's not going anywhere dude i wouldn't
get my green card
yeah are you in the process of getting
your green card i got it i'm just
waiting for my status my my immigration
status to switch which takes like six
months
so i can't leave the country so you've
been here on a work visa the whole time
yeah that's 10 years now or longer than
that really 12 years yeah i've been on
six different visas
so do you do you get double taxed if you
ever go back home
like i was like removed from the
canadian attack system like a long time
ago oh really yeah because wasn't that
an issue if you bought a house they're
like well you might have to declare
double i think that like it is a
question for
residency i think that that's what you
know once you left and you're no longer
a resident of canada then it's like
arguable that like why would you pay
taxes yeah although i've heard you live
there the american system is actually
way more intense about that like it
takes a few years like they still come
after if you move to like portugal or
something like that they'll still come
after you for
for taxes even if you're living there
because we're so in debt that it's
[ __ ] they yeah yeah i think they can
make yeah i don't know if that's true by
the way if a tax lawyer is listening to
this i'd love to know
the logistics of that well i'm looking
at buying a property in canada oh nice
where in british columbia [ __ ] yeah like
bartofino not not tofino not not
vancouver island but uh like suburb of
vancouver nice like this place
that's incredible i love it there yeah
like
i'm really stoked for it but if i've got
a property there and a property here
then it like the tax that's i need a tax
person too so if you're a tax person
if yeah yeah reach out on the website do
you have to worry about global warming
in that area because the pacific
northwest is pretty the pacific
northwest is a hot spot
but it doesn't make sense because i feel
like it's raining there all the time
uh it's summers that are that are
prohibitively cold or it's very hot now
like uh you know we got fires going on
there
but um that's just everywhere now yeah
so
global warming scott it's global
it's kind of everywhere right
um
with the nfts once you like sort of
announce your involvement like what
about all the comments from the people
saying what about the environment you're
destroying the environment i did i never
said that i was doing this i just i just
started because it's not like i'm you
know it's not like i'm doing the logan
paul thing where i'm like making an nft
that has my face on it and i'm like hey
buy my nfc i'm more like in the midst
trading these things with all the kids
that are doing that right now that's why
people because the problem is people are
doing it on the ethereum platform if
they do it on the cardano platform
there's
90 percent less energy to make an nft
i think
i did get those chirps though like cause
when i first like my friend who's an
artist made me a little picture and i
bought it just to like see what this was
like a couple months ago just to see
what it was all about and so i posted i
was like this is my first nft purchase
and every comment was like well you're
burning like you know the fires are
because of you and yeah what about the
environment concerns and i'm like i
don't
it's just it was a chain that said these
nuts on it that was the picture and i
was like this isn't that serious i just
what did i do wrong
that's great i i um
i don't understand it man so like why
isn't email destroying the [ __ ] yeah
i know exactly it's like it's electronic
take a flight in your life that's
probably just as bad right or you live
in a house like
we're all destroying everything yeah for
god's sakes but cardano huh i guess
because it's like proof of work versus
proof of stake right i think the proof
of work is like the computers that are
like constantly mining for these and
that platform's proof of stake which
means
god knows what
but that's like the idea behind it yeah
all right so so let's show uh
let's let's
break down
the top revenue streams
right like i
only fans only fans number one
number two
people love you know
what i got going on underneath this
pornhub number three
it's mostly all porn honestly i mean
like podcasting is legit revenue yeah i
think i think probably
the most lucrative thing for me
personally right now is my youtube
channel okay um i think just because
i've been doing it for so long my cpms
have gone up year over year and i think
i've figured out how to make content
that
um you know people enjoy but also
like is the most efficient in terms of
monetization right and how often are you
uploading like two to three times a week
now damn so i have like a production
assistant who helps me
uh generate like ideas and find content
and stuff like that and then i have two
to three editors that help me out and
this is all like within the past
you know year and a half that i've
figured out how to finally hire and
delegate i used to just do everything
myself so two times and then i'm just
like it's not scalable i'm going insane
two to three times per week and that's
not including podcasts that's not that's
just on my personal channel damn and
then
and then
like i do now i do like two to three
brand deals on that channel a month
too which is also really good i mean
that's like equal to the adsense
basically is there an agency that's
soliciting your brand deals
uh i'm signed with uta okay so they get
me uh
they get me like all of those wow um
and then
it's that and then i think second second
most lucrative probably is the podcast
just because with ads and
patreon combined so adsense actually
competes with uh
sponsored deals for brandon it does yeah
it does youtube went to this period
where like nobody was making money on
adsense because people like advertisers
are so freaked out about
you know their content that content that
they'd be advertising on content that
wasn't suitable for their brand or
whatever right so there's like that's
when the ad pocalypse happened nobody
made any money and then it came back
harder than ever i for me i don't know i
don't know if it's the same with other
people but it's not the same with me
because i i i
like uh
yeah i have trouble keeping those dollar
signs green
yeah yeah yeah that is yeah it is you do
kind of have to like
censor yourself a little bit which is
a little bit short i mean whatever like
i'm sure you don't have to sense
yourself too much i just like the nature
of what i do is like
yeah by the way that video that you
posted of you guys fighting the
anesthesia that was so [ __ ] funny so
much man
just those shots of you like
trying so hard to fight it i was dying
at that thanks dude you held out too
like the doctor had to kind of like push
his head down because he was like even
when he couldn't talk
like your subconscious was like i'm
staying i'm gonna win yeah dying
watching that yeah so do you ever
remember being in that state of mind
like trying to fight it nah
nah auto pilot dude yeah exactly but
yeah dude thanks so much again um so so
adsense is killing it the the brand
deals is killing it i i've struggled to
get brand deals i think the brands just
are kind of freaked out by like you know
the pooh cannon
yeah yeah why would they be i mean right
are you signed with anyone
uh no
like uh
i've got an agent just for touring okay
you know like um i'm icm okay
and i love my touring agent adam
genevizion he's great and it's just that
like for some reason like all the other
departments of the agency just
never like
showed me love you know like i just like
gathered dust everywhere nothing ever
happened and i was like all right i'm
just gonna
you know
pull out and just stick with touring
yeah maybe it's a good time to revisit
because i have like
done a fair amount of work to sort out
yeah you should hit them up for sure i'm
sure the digital
like uh you know part of that industry
would or the agency would love to start
getting you [ __ ]
it's an interesting idea man agency
agents aren't the most
forward-thinking right
they're not the most like i mean i love
my agent she's amazing but um just in
terms of like um being proactive about
stuff
agents mostly in my experience have been
like very reactive right it's like you
come to them you're like look at all the
[ __ ] i'm getting and they're like oh
oh we'll try and get you some stuff for
it's like let's go no one's like doing
research like on your channel right yeah
you're saying that uta is doing that for
you yeah i mean my my agent used to be
my manager and then she got a job for
uta so like she still has that
you know managers are more like intimate
i guess where they really learn like the
ins and outs of your career and she's
been with me now for like seven years or
something
so
now she's my agent but typically like
i don't know agents are i don't know
they're always busy with having a
million clients you know right are they
they're very good at picking up the
phone yeah yeah what sorry
picking a phone to answer calls yeah
yeah right not not really dialing yeah
exactly um do are you exclusive with uta
in the branded
the digital and branded deals uh i full
screen used to get me those as well
uh yeah so it was like but now the whole
screen's gone
i got an important question quite a
question to ask you your whoop strap
yeah what's your hrv
you know what what's your idea what my
recovery was today because your dad and
your mom both do like yeah they're
interested in triathlons and iron man
forgot to turn it off after my workouts
i've been working out for four and a
half hours let's see that's why but i'm
just curious to see what your your
resting hrv is
today was 59 59 59 wow i would expect
you to be over a hundred yesterday or
like last week is 54 60 so you stayed
you're my my wrestling heart rate not
hrv your hrv is the right variability
yeah right right so what what is that
like how does that convert
right here yeah 48. oh 40 yeah it came
60.
54. yeah it's your favorite what are you
doing nominally i'm at like same with
you 50 or 60. steve's at like 130.
what's 140. so do you get like 100
recovery every day no and recover uh but
the higher recovery the higher the hrv
right yeah let's not like alienate the
listeners i mean we love whoop and shout
out to the
whoop
it's pretty rare that we record a
podcast and it goes up the next day yes
this one's going live tomorrow okay cool
and today happy thursday people yeah
dude [ __ ] right on today the
paramount pictures announced that
jackass forever is not in fact coming
out on october 22nd but they're pushing
it to february 4th
next year due to coven jack asked for
later oh because it they want it and
caterpillars the delta
yeah the delta you know whatever so yeah
february 4th is a new release date my
dad speculates that covert is going to
be even worse
february
then you think so i don't know
i mean i'm stoked for the new jackass
thanks man we were watching it's really
fun we just watched the the original
jackass movie like two months ago we
were still figuring out what we were
doing with the original jackass it was
just kind of felt like you know it been
it had its own quality to it then
jackass number two we had figured out
what we were doing that was the
masterpiece yeah jackass number three
was the biggest financial success but
like not even the best movie
and and this fourth one
is uh
we'll never beat number two but we
smashed number three dude we [ __ ] we
walked all over number three dude like
in turn like financially
[Music]
it's so [ __ ] good and uh dude so we
had this this call with the like the the
cast where they announced to us that
they're gonna push the movie
and and dave england's like no
hands on his head he's like you could
just see the agony in his face and i
said dave dude what are you talking
about like the trailer came out there's
a big buzz around the movie you know
like we're kind of hot [ __ ] right now
and the second that movie comes out
we're washed up losers again you know
the more they can kick it down the road
the longer we're hot [ __ ]
there you go you're like i hope this
thing never comes out right
carter finally baby i hope coco keeps
getting worse actually
carter five baby
yeah dude so so we got adsense we got
brand deals we got podcasts and we just
got into the merch drops yeah
i've done merch for a while but finally
i like i'm with a company that's super
organized really proactive so what's the
company uh it's called kozak
okay they're amazing shout out to kozak
what do they do is it like teespring or
something no they're just the guy owns a
factory like somewhere close la and so
he prints
he prints everything himself fulfills
the orders yes i do everything so like
it's you know typically you know i've
been with merch companies that do
pre-orders so like they'll wait to see
how many you sell and then they'll go
into distribution right and ship them
out so that takes a long time for people
and they're like where's my merch like a
month later and then you know i've been
with people that do [ __ ] right away
but aren't as proactive in terms of
planning your upcoming drops and
analyzing what's worked and what hasn't
worked they're more of like a you're on
your own we're going to print and ship
that's all we're going to do yeah and
these guys are a perfect mix of of
everything where it's like people get
their merch really fast they help you
plan out drops they'll they have great
relationships with amazing artists
um
i just like i'm thrilled honestly so
they've helped me like increase my
revenue but it took me like six years
to find a you know a really good
relationship what about what about music
music
music has to have been in the top three
because dude i'm getting back in the
music game i got to are you yeah yeah
yeah there was a minute that before i
got sober i was trying to make comedy
rap yeah and uh
it's fun dude yeah you got to give
yourself a timeline though i know i do
i've got like i've got like
uh one
idea for a song that's [ __ ] gonna be
a big i've got two ideas for songs
they're going to be bangers how many
songs you want to have on the album dude
six i mean what do you think dude gotta
have like at least ten right what were
we talking about yeah probably for an
album like 12
ep you could do
four or five songs
um or you could just start dropping
singles you know yeah
is this a good rap song
i [ __ ] my pants
like damn i [ __ ] my pants why is this
based off
is hot
gold did this just happen to you
recently
but uh
i like it but i mean i have [ __ ] my
pants before
that's why it's sick because it's
relatable i know i've shaved my pants
before and i i i think i can really like
you know
convey that that emotion yeah
translate it i think it's good i made
one that i never released i still want
to release it because i want to shoot a
video for it but it's it was called
uh she's a freak
and the whole the first verse is about
how she's like you know i would like
meet this girl in the club and i want to
take her home
and then we get home and she's a total
freak but it's like she's an actual
monster like she's got like wings and
like like gills and just like she's a
complete freak that'd be a good video
i've got a tune like that
about my actual fiance okay where it
like
where it's like a beautiful love song
she's the perfect woman for me like uh
you know
our love is so real
but then that [ __ ] week
[ __ ] on the calendar shows up
you know okay it's just a song about
what a [ __ ] my girl is when she's on
the rack
yeah
she's going to love it
she's already into it really she's
already down oh my god
you know i mean whatever maybe not the
way i just worded
it but yeah like you know she's like
just like it's called like you know
the
angel angel and demon you know like it's
not it's not called you're a total [ __ ]
on the rack
because that's
about an hour i feel like this hasn't
been for me my best job of running a
pocket but it's also been very informal
and like we're just hanging out it might
have been my fault because
i'm just i want to hang with you guys
because like i said i watched the show
so it's like an honor for me to i feel
like you know when you listen to a
podcast i wish i could ask them that so
i took this opportunity to like dude ask
you guys questions
i'm enjoying this a lot this is great oh
they got it it's been it's been a fun
thing it's been a fun hang yeah and i i
don't mind saying that cody ko is a
[ __ ]
just one earring it's just like a
legitimately like eight-year-old girl
haircut
i think you're legit hot dude i used to
have a joke in my stand up he's like i
used to have a crush on you
i used to have a joke in my stand up i
would
i'd be like man what a great crowd dude
like uh this is like a hot dude right
here
and then um
i'd say like you know like that's me man
i'm perfectly comfortable
saying when a dude is hot you know yeah
oh yeah like uh
like most guys if if you ask him is is
this guy hot they'd be like dude would
you think i'm some kind of goo dude yeah
i'm not good man right but they know
exactly when to be jealous of a hot dude
talking to their girls sure so clearly
every guy knows when another guy's hot
oh yeah you know a hot dude when you see
one oh yeah i have a question and i'm
down with with admitting that i'm down
with calling it out you're saying you
know like you're not welcome to talk to
my girl
you know
like right here you're not welcome to
talk to my girl you're not
you're good
yeah and then that's the job like you
you could take her to dinner
you're fine i got no worries
for the weekend yeah dude
yeah
yeah i mean you'd be disturbed if like
lux came home and she was like dude i
have a friend from work that wants to
hang out his name's cody yeah
you do appreciate a good looking man i
did more than most you you you're more
than you call it out yeah did i call you
the gorgeous pop risky on this i don't
know on this episode if you did probably
you were distracted by cody's eyes
right i like to surround myself with a
hot dude so this has been a very
enjoyable hour but you told me i was
good looking the day i met you oh good
do you remember i met you at vidcon i
don't know if you even remember vidcon
like yucca brought me over to you to
like meet you he's like yeah this is
paul by the way and you're like hey
good looking dude
it's like the first thing you said
you're hot as [ __ ] by the way yeah i say
that regularly but only when it's a hot
dude right yeah i'm a straight shooter
yeah absolutely
well i appreciate that because i get you
know i get ripped apart on my channel
for no for what well just because like
i've i've established this energy of
like i make fun of things so people are
like it's free game to make fun of you
which it totally is i'm down to make fun
of myself but it's like you know
the compliments are pretty few and far
between
is there anything that ever just like
hurts your feelings though or is are you
pretty
water off the ducks back to all the kids
i think everybody gets sensitive like
you know i'm pretty in it sorry dinner
but it's like as i get older i get more
fragile i feel like yeah you know
but also more you don't give a [ __ ]
anymore i was telling paul because paul
hadn't been around for the last couple
of episodes and people thought it was
some like conspiracy
and they they saw me with the pillow
right here and they're like dude scott's
covering up the sound board because
paul's not around and i'm like i'm
covering i have a pillow over me because
i'm fat
like i wrote that back on the comment
and
and it's it's just so funny that people
think different conspiracies but i'm
just like no dude like
what to me is heartening is that people
care enough to pay that much attention
like that's [ __ ] beautiful yeah but
yeah you're like it's like
when an actress is pregnant on a sitcom
you know they're always trying to like
hide it
[ __ ] it the reality of why paul was gone
is that oh we never changed to lavender
for you that paul was gone because he
wanted to propose to his girl and took
two [ __ ] weeks to do it and then once
he finally came back
then he went to some other bros bachelor
party and both of these were like
distant like uh interstate
trips
yeah you have any more people you're
going to propose to in the next couple
weeks yeah
there was a wedding now for the that the
bachelor party was for
is that going to be another trip to
florida
no that's a but it's a trip to the
midwest seven months
isn't it just like a million weddings
now yeah how old are you i'm 31. yeah
it's just like
every weekend it's crazy how old are you
i'm 30. you're 30. almost 31. i'm 31 in
november so i'm pretty close but you
guys are at the age where people get
married i'm at the age where people get
divorced
so i don't have anything to go to for
the next while
i just put it together too scott's
taught like i'm like what's he doing
with the pillar now and i'm like oh yeah
it's hot as balls we have an air
conditioner here in full blast and
scott's wearing a [ __ ] winner a
winter coat yeah [ __ ] body dysmorphia
dude
scott you're beautiful i feel beautiful
good i've always been gorgeous man you
don't call me gorgeous anymore dude wow
because you got fat
i don't say that
no i'm just kidding i love it
what can we drive people to tomorrow um
today you know
jackass for
coming out in february i want to drive
some traffic to uh
the the truth or dab to go buy the the
the
destroyer comes out today we just
[ __ ] came out with stevo's butthole
destroyer
i'm so scared that someone's gonna be
like oh cool let me pour it in my eye
because this is not like to do [ __ ]
silly [ __ ] with the top three
ingredients are the three hottest
peppers on earth so it's it's really
that hot it's so [ __ ]
like the first thing on the ingredient
list is what there's the most of in the
bottle and that's scorpion
ghost
and carolina reaper that's the filler
scorpion
peppers on earth yeah that's the bottle
more than anything else did you do uh
truth or dab or whatever yeah so like
how does it compare to the bomb or like
that spiciest one because one of them
[ __ ] me up i like i felt drunk
afterwards i had like a solid hour after
i had like a head buzz really yeah it
was crazy tomorrow's september 2nd when
it came out comes out
yeah so it's a double upload day and
it's me and we man on truth or dare
except for us it's truth and dab
there's no question that we want kids to
avoid and and there was no wing we cared
to avoid
plus that we all
uh
we all dipped into the butthole
destroyer and is it how does it compare
to the bomb
i mean i i think like candidly
before we recorded the truth or dab i
asked sean evans i said it i said i
liked it
is it like i gonna bum you guys out if i
point out that like
butthole destroyer is hotter than
anything you've ever had on your show
because they're like kind of celebrity
centric yeah you know like they can't
really like give like these huge
celebrities
butthole destroyer because it's so
[ __ ] hot yeah is it that hot compared
to the [ __ ] on there i think so but then
you can
now let me not disparage hot ones they
get some hot ass [ __ ] yeah i'm not even
really sure i'm not even really sure all
i know is that butthole destroyer is so
[ __ ] up that when we were doing taste
tests i straight up tapped out by
putting a little bit on a tortilla chip
and was [ __ ]
like
putting ice cubes in my mouth like 45
minutes later damn yeah let this be the
disclaimer do not [ __ ] around this hot
sauce it's hot as [ __ ] dude don't put it
in your eye definitely don't put it in
your ass
definitely don't put it in your eye
i'm thinking about putting it in my ass
wow i'm thinking about it
i don't know i almost did
like when it was again like yesterday
yeah yeah i talked about about uh
actually doing it yesterday and then i
was like you know what i'm not i'm good
all right so cody co on instagram yeah
or youtube or you know whatever tiny
meat gang is my podcast um
and your music tiny meat gang yep check
them out on spotify um thanks for having
me i really just yeah it was like a
blast
i hadn't even put it together oh yeah
that's right that we that we [ __ ]
hung out in vancouver
and then we bailed in montreal
yeah i was in montreal yeah montreal the
montreal uh comedy festival yeah yeah i
did the montreal vancouver and toronto
that year oh nice
yeah yeah it was fun
yeah it was a good time i remember that
that after party was kind of sick yeah
at the bar like in the hotel yeah it was
pretty fun and montreal is a cool place
yeah i love it there yeah yeah
all right thanks dude i appreciate it
man thank you great to meet you nice to
meet you great to meet you guys see you
again yeah appreciate it yeah dude
yeah dude
i was not kidding about i'm getting
ready to bone luxe that's what i'm
saying so uh
there's been a few times where we
actually recorded the podcast on the
day before it went out
like uh
it's exciting man
you love a good current podcast you know
what else i love
you man for sticking around to the very
end
you ever see this guy he's a real jerk
but you aren't thank you yeah
[Music]